sure what's that symbol means we have a
couple of new characters that were
really excited about that means anarchy
the first is another villain we're going
to bring in the Batman villain anarchy
he's going to be a lot like Damian and
that he's also very sociopathic but
we're gonna get the opportunity to
really see the birth of a villain we're
gonna really see what happens
why does Lonnie Machin become Anarchy
what happens to him and the cool thing
about it is we're going to set it up so
that it really is Oliver and to some
extent Thea's fault that Lonnie Machin
goes the direction that he goes and
Lonnie will also blame Damian for a lot
of what happens to him so he's going to
actually be an interesting character and
that he's opposed to both our Big Bad
and to our hero
hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
some new arrow footage that focuses a
lot on anarchy so I'm gonna do a
breakdown for his character and then
explain what arrow might be changing
about the character they always do like
their version of comic book characters
that are usually true to the comics but
then kind of take it off in a different
direction it's like the way Laurel Lance
is actually the Black Canary from the
comics but they had a canary before that
that was Sara Lance so that you know
they changed minor things but relatively
speaking this will be a little bit
closer to the new 52 anarchy that
they're been a couple different
characterizations for him in the comics
going way way back it was even a period
after 9/11 in the United States when DC
just kind of like quietly put him on the
shelf as a character if they're like
okay we don't need too many characters
espousing this kind of philosophy but I
mean obviously he came back during the
new 52 as Wendy miracle said this is
gonna be something of an origin story
for the character and thankfully I'm I'm
actually really excited about this
both Oliver Queen team arrow and damian
darhk-- the villains will be responsible
for anarchy becoming anarchy
it's kind of like Oliver Queen being
responsible for the creation of
Deathstroke with the mirakuru storyline
during season two so heroes dirt push
Anarchy down a dark path damian darhk--
pushes his will on anarchy also pushes
him down a dark path and like she said
just because anarchy is gonna be working
with damian darhk-- doesn't mean that
he's going to end up liking him he'll
end up fighting against damian darhk--
too so he'll kind of be like this third
force off by himself so going back in
the comics there's a quick origin story
for the character the original version
of anarchy was named Lonnie Mackin and
he was actually a twelve-year-old child
I may have fought against him but
because Lonnie used other agents like
other homeless men to fight for him it
took Batman a little while to figure out
that he was a little kid Lonnie would
like right in and correct newspapers and
generally act through other agents he
was like the original angry internet
commenter back when the internet didn't
exist people would write into newspapers
to complain about stuff I'm sure there's
still a lot of people that do that but
eventually Batman defeats him Lonnie is
sent to a juvenile detention center he
didn't have any special powers or
anything like that he just had a really
quick wit and a strong philosophy the
character had his own title for a little
while called Batman anarchy and then
just like an anarchy standalone title
but because of 9/11 and because the
character wasn't super popular DC
cancelled the title they're very quick
to do that when things aren't going well
they actually axed a whole bunch of like
the new titles that they just rolled out
then in 2008 they were looking for new
villains to put in a Tim Drake title in
a robbing title they wanted to bring
anarchy back but they wanted like a new
more hardcore version of the character
so they had Ulysses Armstrong take the
title from Lonni Mackin and Lonnie Mac
and took the name money spider so it was
kind of like handing off the mantle
there was a cartoon series called beware
the batman on Cartoon Network where
Anarchy showed up they wanted to use him
as more of a Moriarty character so it
invoked a lot of detective Batman versus
just like you know punching kicking
Batman if you played the arkham origins
game anarchy was a part of that too then
during the new 52 they introduced a new
version of the character that was
african-american briefly before they
retconned everything they actually never
revealed his true identity either
and then finally post new 52 they
introduced a character named Sam young
that took the mantle
and he was more of a corrupt politician
so it's a slightly different
characterization on anarchy so I think
that's the closest thing to the version
we're gonna see on arrow
but you know just just in general
combining a lot of things from Anarchy's
history in the comics albeit coming from
the world of politics as you can see
right here he's actually standing right
next to Jeri Ryan she's actually showing
up in an episode called
the candidate so I'm wondering if the
candidate also refers to Anarchy's
character so don't be surprised on the
TV show if when we first meet him he's
just like a normal person with some
really strong ideas and damian darhk--
tries to co-opt him he doesn't have any
superpowers or anything like that but he
is a child prodigy Italy at least the
original version of the character so
they might give some of those aspects to
the aro version they are being nice
though and giving this character this
Anarchy character the Lonnie MCing name
so when we meet him we're just gonna
meet Lonnie Mackin and he will slowly
become an Archie I don't know if he's a
series regular but I do think that he
will make it to the back half of the
season just that sometimes they
introduce villains that they deal with
like in the first couple of episodes or
like the first half of the season and
then they introduce some new villains to
the second half the comodo who barely
showed up at all last year and then you
have overarching villains that get
developed through the entire season like
Slade and actually just just to clarify
that was a bit of a special case Slade
was present in the flashbacks and in
present day they're actually changing
the way they do the flashbacks it's
gonna be like its own storyline
thematically it's gonna line up with
what's going on in present day like look
it'll all make sense together this is
one big story between past and present
but largely it's going to be its own
cell
contains story with different characters
Stephen Amell said something funny about
it recently he just said they're being
very secretive about their flashback
scenes so I'm guessing they're using
some pretty big characters they've
announced some of the minor villains but
I'm really hoping that we get to see
Carol Ferris like that's that's the big
rumor but that remains to be seen
there's just a theory at this point and
there's actually still a lot of talk
going on about the new firestorm from
yesterday so obviously he's gonna be
like a Jason Rusch type character
they're gonna do the handoff but they
might actually be doing a different
version of the character even though
they're calling him Jay Jackson his bio
reads like new 52 jason rusch so it's a
little bit confusing now but like once
we see the first couple episodes it'll
completely explain everything that's why
I'm always so happy when the show's
finally come back just because you you
actually get to see what they really
ended up doing most of the biggest
people will introduce those episodes the
only exception is gonna be Vandal Savage
he's actually not gonna get his big
introduction until episode 8 of flash
and arrow like the big crossover they're
filming that right now like as we speak
Stephen Amell said they had 200 extras
on the set the other day for a TV show
on the CW that is a shitload of extras
so whatever they're doing it's gonna be
huge and they're all dressed in fineries
let me know that why do you think that
everyone is dressed so nicely like what
are these scenes that they're filming
are and remember this is the arrow flash
crossover why you guys theorycraft on
that I will say congratulations to Malik
Tuan you win the reverse flash ring
giveaway this week next week because
it's special it's the premiere I'll give
a couple extra weight normally it's one
giveaway per fandom per week but you
know but whenever there's like a
premiere finale I try to beef it up so
lots of swag be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's actually there's so much
exciting stuff that's gonna be happening
this year well you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
watch the arrow and flash trailers that
I've posted like 3 or 4 or 5 more times
and you can click here to catch up with
agents of shield from last night they
just aired episode 1
guardians of the galaxy references a
little bit of Doctor Strange Avengers
age of Ultron all kinds of crazy Marvel
stuff thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys can I